[Music]
rough times for mitt romney have you
heard this
thanks
no apparently they've been writing about
this since losing the election mitt
romney is reportedly bored
yeah after hearing this ann romney said
you're bored i'm sitting around all day
with mitt romney
that's the problem she's like
i'm bi
former vice president dick cheney is
writing a book about his health problems
yeah
the uh the book is called life of too
much pie
sorry that was um
sorry
i'm sorry that's just awful
that's awful that should never have
happened
a lot of uh dissension among
conservatives one of the leaders of the
tea party has resigned after a major
split in the movement
yeah
the tea party is now divided between
angry whites and even angrier whites
that's a problem we've got to get them
together right
gonna bring this country together
kate middleton having a baby isn't that
exciting
not our country
new mom snooki new mom snooki
snooki says she wants to give baby
advice to kate middleton
snooki said her number one tip is find
out who the father is
any star wars fans here
[Applause]
[Music]
why
some of those noises don't match up with
star wars
people going
like star wars nine or something uh no
good news for star wars fans federal
officials announced they will allow
disney to purchase george lucas george
lucas's company they will allow that to
go through
the officials were initially worried it
would create a monopoly but then obi-wan
waved his hand in front of them suddenly
it was cool
[Applause]
it's not a monopoly it's not a monopoly
no reason to act that out
um
hey
kim kardashian's in the news kim
kardashian's been touring the middle
east touching off angry protests among
conservative muslims
yeah
yeah it's funny you think conservative
muslims would be happy to see a woman
who's never had a job
isn't that what they're all about
i'm serious
that lines up nicely yes
check this out in russia
there was a
125 mile traffic jam that had drivers
stuck in traffic for over three
days yeah here in los angeles that's
known as friday
[Applause]
chris brown in the news chris brown was
photographed in amsterdam with three
joints in his mouth
brown was so high he almost punched a
man
what's going on the ceo of the olive
garden
blames his company's low profits on
obamacare
which is odd because most people won't
eat at the olive garden until they have
health insurance i thought about that
true story
thank you the irs
[Laughter]
it's a very it's a very gentle exchange
here you give a joke and they
clap guys
and they're like we'd like to hear
another
that was good now i think one more
i think we're done but thanks
hey gang check this out
the irs seized lindsay lohan's bank
account
because she owes 233 000 in bank taxes
yeah seized her bank account yeah they
were going to take her car too but they
couldn't get it out of the tree
thank you